eight news now a news station that
probably supports the community and in
many different ways yeah channel it's
always been like that today is our
Founders Day of caring and we're
collecting donations for three local
non-profits Candace Charles is live this
morning at one of them hope link of
Southern Nevada down in Henderson with
the impact that we can all make together
Henderson uh Candace good morning to you
good morning John and Heather yes you
know here AIDS now we're all about
giving back to the community it's our
77th annual Founders Day of caring
you'll see some of us working throughout
the community today out at project
Maryland Gathering up and and packing up
the freedom hygiene products we've been
collecting all week as well as a Helping
Hands packing up non-perishable items
we've been collecting for our seniors
we've added up some donations as well
for Hope link and right now we're
beautifying it and I have Catherine for
Elizabeth here with me now thank you so
much for joining us this morning to talk
a little bit about what you guys do here
hopefully thank you for joining us this
morning and coming out to help us here
at hopelink we're helping individuals
seniors and families in crisis so that's
providing case management rental utility
assistant rapid re-housing emergency
shelter and Workforce Development so you
do a lot for the community and I know a
lot of those dollars go out more than
they do come in so how are we helping
you guys today make this place even more
beautiful so every dollar that we have
we want to go to our client we really
pride ourselves on uh 94 cents on every
dollar we have coming in going back to
our clients and so since we're so
focused on our clients we rarely get to
beautify our own space and so we're so
grateful to Star Nursery and channel 8
for coming out today to help beautify
our grounds because you know rocks
they're maybe good for the environment
but don't give you that warm hug that
you need when you type it absolutely
thank you so much Captain if all you do
in the community you guys see a few of
our people that are on camera stop right
over there you guys will see them all
this morning and throughout the day it's
quite exciting I have my shovel I don't
really know if I'm gonna do anything
with this shovel but we shall see I've
always got to cover with more details on
about the 80s now.com if you want to
donate you're still getting by going to
our website to find the links to our
nonprofits we're working but for now
live from up link out at Henderson I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now South world
shovel and she doesn't know how to use
it okay we wanted to prove we wanted to
prove they're working because we turned
the shovel sounds up to 11. right so now
you know for sure thank you Candace for
the cacti yeah